en effet rebond soir en soir thierry le
président du jury du festival du film
policier à cognac du 17 au 23 avril qui
propose une rétrospective de ses films
il y en a un que j'ai fait verneuil avec
deux verres jeanne moreau qui s'appelle
mille milliards de dollars
je reviens avec beaucoup de tendresse et
d'affection surtout à cause de patrick
pasquier tous les regards sont
formidables c'était très très tristes
sentir disparu
jones est une personne que j'admire
depuis longtemps mais vers là et c'est
le grand maître c'est un des seuls 4 y
existe aujourd'hui
nationale
l'ange des voyous ouais y'a l'ange des
maudits aussi avec marlène de freaks
train
qui est ici à paris comme souvent les
petites ou de suisse jamais on a essayé
de l'arrêter dans l'ue naturel veut pas
venir même avec des lunettes noires ils
parlent même pas au téléphone a remarqué
triste toute façon bonsoir marin
il ya le soleil se lève aussi soleil se
lève
avec un regard amer
trois parcs et être un grand copain a
connu bien avant elle est à quai et les
très rigolo
fm
et gesca qu tu as connu dans ta vie tout
là un maximum de gens alors on va les
prendre comme ça à part ajustements papa
[Musique]
alors marlene dietrich comment ça s'est
passé
et bien vite
et mal elle ne s'entendait pas c'est
comme ça parce qu'il était très jaloux
de mon père
parce que lui avait parlé d' un peu plus
tard quoi ouais l'autre avait eu à la
bonne école joseph acheteurs et
finalement on travaille ensemble et se
détester cordiale il fait michel fritz
ont tué litre et 1 était élue elle it is
a big burgers
ils atteignent chose que j'aie tour est
tellement à faire que j'ai pris comme ça
et j'ai dit at il rapidement des parts
de l'appareil tourne plus il a demandé
pardon il y avait là celle de la mort
alors elle prend la balle pour le sauver
la victime est un mélodrame on a tous vu
qu'ils s'améliorent elles sont devant
moi pour nous protéger d'un soir à bâle
et non mais par il faut que jamais sur
le devant et tout ça elana mille un
objectif ici dray avait déjà un certain
âge ça ne m'était pas vraiment en valeur
mais
ici c'est mieux ces patates et une
grande histoire et que ward use aussi
parce qu'on t'a appelé pour terminer un
film s'appelait vendetta moi ce que tu
sais ça
m'a téléphoné mardi à what you'd va
t'appeler dans dans 10 minutes
accrochées ne touche pas c'est un hymne
à peine entrevoir le soir même j'ai dit
j'ai une semaine de travail pour vous
deux jours fait patients deux jours de
tournage deux jours de montage bastin et
deux ans après ouais c'est parce qu'il a
le trac mais c'était vendetta d'après
d'après meriem est
encore inconnu howard duke c'est le
moment il faisait cet avion qui n'a
jamais décollé finalement pour le
gouvernement récemment que même après 4
piégé avec les soirs gouvernement
américain qui lui avait dit si ça vole
on vous le bay sinon c'est pour savoir
quel était le dernier jour justement à
travailler ensemble le soir même ils
riaient record et se marrait aspire à
qu'il a touché un chèque je pars aux 12
millions $ est parce qu il a fait sa
volée à fait là où il a pu toucher et
l'avion maintenant on est toujours là
bas toujours est en bois sacré
personnage quand marc a été merveilleux
s'est acheté près certain qu'il avait
acheté le désertines las vegas aussi
racheté voulait qui cisaille de la
chance alors y avait déjà cette l'hôtel
c'est ça non c'est vrai
il a dit aussi
il ya en face il y à
savon d'une enseigne savent ennuyer
wepad armée d'hommes il dormait très mal
toute façon alors ça faisait prendre
à aider achète moi cet hôtel sans qu'ils
aient acheté non seulement le désert dit
m et en face
et tu sais comment il a fini parce que
personne ne sait comment comment ça
s'est terminé son histoire il ment parce
qu'ils n'avaient pas machine de dial
s'il avait
un qui avait besoin d'une machine il
était à kaboul où ils étaient près
d'acapulco dans un hôtel il a pas mal en
acheter motel ouest et la balle que
semaine et
c'est pas pour quelle raison il n'y
avait pas de machines de dialyse comment
ce qu'on peut dire 'je suis tout à fait
et on a mis dans l'avion et on entend
les vers le texas wii avait cette
machine éléments dans la viande si oui
ce qu'ont raconté à la fin de sa vie qui
est qui se droguait qui vivait tout seul
drogués dans un penthouse du du
désertines moi je n'ai pas vu à ce
moment là je sais pas si c'est tout
rires étaient certainement tout seul il
était soigné par des normands est un peu
même prisonnier du moment dont un peu
mais il avait tellement peur d'attraper
une maladie quelconque winch et jean ex
aequo il avait des grands de la 4e fois
ci c'est avec un kleenex y passer sa
journée au lit en verlan et kiev qui
gardaient toujours le même film et la
déception projecteurs à côté des regards
des recettes additionnelles
passé chez cbre 1 mon dieu c'était bien
renseignés
alors on en arrive à la fin du gouffre
où on arrive à audrey bird tu t'en
doutes ça te fait ça devait arriver vous
êtes rencontrés comment et pas comment
ça commence mais pour montrer comment je
sois pas qui c'est y qui la présentait
il venait de terminer et à quand même
et
mais j'étais tout seul depuis pas mal de
temps
et 31
appuyé par se marier du club histoire
avec william holden
c'est pas du tout elle n'a jamais craqué
pour william holden par tous âges tous
les lecteurs de ciné revue ciné monde te
regarde ils ont tourné ensemble ils
travaillent ensemble à ce moment avec
les waratahs mettre en scène
mais ça c'est
armel dans tous ces personnages que tu
as tu as connu dans ta vie qui sont tous
des noms de légende c'est c'est le cas
le plus étonnant
je dirais l'ap les états lancé radieux
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de nos
latitudes abonnez vous il m'était
impossible eux